so welcome to my talk about julia in
python's then
julia has
some bold claims like that it looks like
python feels like lisp and runs like c
which is somehow true and somehow isn't
so we'll take a look at this
so something about me i'm working as
machine learning engineer at avast slash
like a aiops engineer
and i've been using python for almost
six years and more than two and a half
years with julia
i'm on github and many other social
networks
so
what i'll be talking about today
uh i'll tell you what is julia and how
does it compare to python like if you
have some project and you will have
python as your default because this is
pi data and you'll be deciding whether
you want to use julia or not like what
should you
consider
why to use julia instead of python
or why not and when
of course i'll share with you some
experience with running julia in
production because at avast we're
running some applications in julia at
production in production for more than
one year
and it's still running and somehow works
and also you can call julia from python
and call python from julia which is
quite neat but has some
disadvantages
so the context why julia has been
created like why we need yet another
programming language like there wouldn't
be
too many of them already
if
okay so who has heard about julia before
okay quite a lots of people perfect
and who has tried to code something in
julia
few people thank you you're very brave
so
for the rest of you why would you be
interesting julia in general if you are
doing machine learning i guess
who has done some machine learning here
at least some fitting some mathematical
model okay
so quite a lot
so
you may know that you need some
flexibility because you just need to do
lots of prototyping and trying out
different approaches but you also need
speed because you have lots of data and
python itself is quite slow and quite
bad at handling data on its own that's
why we have all the pi data
stack like numpy tensorflow pythorg
scikit scikit-learn sci-fi and so on
which are basically c c plus plus and
fortran beckons with python wrappers and
that makes them really fast
and lets you do
some serious computations using the
flexibility of python which is cool but
it has the disadvantage that you have
two languages so you have the
performance language and the flexible
language which uses wrapper for the
performance one usually
you are quite okay with it if you are
doing some basic stuff but if you are
figuring out hunting down some bugs and
you figure out that you are debugging
through the python and you find out that
the bug is inside the fortran or inside
the c plus plus you're quite screwed
unless you are proficient in c plus pass
or fortran
so julia tries to solve this by having
one language which is as flexible as
python and as performant as c plus plus
of or fortran or c
so julia is good for of course machine
learning mathematical modeling
simulations and differentiable
programming
i don't think it is it makes sense to
use julia for anything else than this
apart from
some educational purposes because
for explaining neural networks and
expanding differential programming i
find julia quite useful because i think
it's easier to install julia than
tensorflow
in some cases and the code looks simpler
and looks more like math which is useful
when you are trying to describe the
concepts
so
you need as i said you need the
speed and the flexibility
and the current solutions are
somehow
two languages
and you either are stuck with python and
can't debug in cpus pass or you need to
master two languages
so julia started already 10 years ago
though but they were working quite a lot
for many years when it was in under
heavy development and four years ago
almost four years ago with the version 1
100 was released and since then there
were many other
newer versions the latest stable version
was released like one month ago and
there is also lts the long term support
version which is
the 166 released due at late march
so in general julia is high level high
performance
dynamic language for technical computing
the nice things about julia are that it
in the standard libraries it supports
distributed parallel execution so you
can perform computations on some cluster
out of the box using just the standard
libraries don't need
anything else it has good numerical
accuracy and sophisticated compiler the
compiler is compiler is llvm who has
heard about llvm
okay few people so for the rest of you
llvm is low level virtual machine is
basically something like virtual machine
but it compiles your code into the
native co machine code so it compiles to
really fast code that pro the cpu
understands well
and if it gets compiled properly it's
really fast as as fast as c
julia has rebel which you probably know
the interactive shell where you can type
things and
computations happen
and julian can also run in jupiter
notebook quite natively maybe you know
that when jupiter was invite was founded
or invite
invented in 2014
it actually standed for the name
actually stands for
julia python r because from the
beginning the jupiter project was
designed to support r python and also
julia from the beginning out of the box
julia is probably the only
high-level language which is able of
petascale compute
that was achieved during the celeste
project
where it ran on the quarry supercomputer
and it achieved 1.5
petaflop per second there are there are
other projects which were able to
achieve this
performance but they were in fortran or
crc plus maybe python could do it
if
these people got
to big enough cluster because you can't
achieve this without a really big
cluster
so this is
a benchmark to show you how fast julia
can get this is somehow mandatory slide
to show to people when we are talking
about julia
so
you have some benchmarks
oh yeah you can see some benchmarks you
have the c for reference and then you
have dots for
how
fast or slow it's compared to c so
fortran has many benchmarks faster than
c
julia is sometimes a bit better but
sometimes a bit slower than c
and the other languages are quite slow
the octave being the worst
so why would you want to use julia julia
looks and feels quite like a python if i
should compare it i think python is the
closest to julia in the
syntax that it looks very
quite similar
it's
generally fast like c but has some
caveats like you need to know something
about type system and
write type stable code because if your
code is typed unstable it's as slow as
python
julia has
matlab like
math notations which i think is nice
because it really looks like math and
because julia also supports a unicode
you can
name your variables and
using the greek letters so it really can
look like math
but it's quite performant code which i
like
the statistics i think it's quite easy
to do in julia because it look more like
math
so i would say it's as easy as in r but
maybe quite bold statement
julia has multiple dispatch who knows
what is multiple dispatch
okay few people so multiple dispatch is
a property of language that if you have
function you can have different
implementations for different
types of the inputs it's a bit like the
overloading or inheritance but
it works the same for all arguments and
you can dispatch on
different arguments and
specialize your code for different for
many arguments of your functions so that
lets you write generic yet performant
code for some use cases
which can be really nice
and
as you can call c from python which is
quite easy because python the c python
interpreter is based on c so the c
extensions are quite natural
you can call also see from julia you can
call also fortran from julia but that's
same with python and you can also call
python from julia and julia from python
which is nice
julia has for our computic which is more
powerful than python because as we know
python has gill
jill
yeah gill so julia doesn't have the
global interpetrolog which is very nice
and makes you
lets you utilize the threats
in much powerful manner and it can also
quite well
multi-process using several processes at
once
it has built-in package manager which
has a good support of git so you can
just
take any git repo which has the
conventions of julia package and use it
as your package
which is nice which is nice and julia
has great type system as you may know in
python in python everything under the
hood is just pi object which is the
value and some metadata about it
and the
interpreter can't optimize much because
it doesn't know that well what type of
is it so if you want some really high
performance code you use numpy or numba
which do some kind of type inference or
use strict typing because as we know
numpy uses strict typing and you can't
mix different data types in numpy
or tensorflow or pytorch
and julia is general purpose in the
sense that you can theoretically write
anything in julia but you like the
ecosystem
which is why i'm getting to why you
would not want to use julia julia is
still quite young the ecosystem isn't
mature enough there is lots of libraries
and lots of them is in version o point
something which we probably know from
python a few years ago
but finally we have pandas one point
something which is great
python
some packages are not stable enough
which is a bit unpleasant sometimes the
documentation isn't good enough and
there isn't enough examples so you get
stuck with reading
the tests reading the source code
which can be challenging
it lacks some external tooling and
corporate support from some tools for
example at avast we are using
artifactory which is like general
package manager supports many languages
and tools but doesn't support julia
so when we want to use julia in
production we need to figure out how we
want to package our internal packages
when the main
package repository doesn't support this
which was quite fun
there is no jetbrains ide which is very
sad you can find julia
extension for pipe
for pycharm and intellij but it sucks
and two years ago i reported many bugs
and they haven't resolved them
so in julia we use vs code which is
under level which is
being developed quite a lot and
is quite pleasant to work in
there isn't many things on stack
overflow for julia which is very sad
you can find some things but definitely
not many and julia community has
discourse who has heard about this
course
yeah no one that's the issue no one
knows it
so it's kind some kind of forum
which is also like question answer based
so people are asking there other
people's are answering you can upvote
the quest or heart the questions
but it's also not
big enough to actually support you in
your daily work as well as the stack
overflow supports you when you are
coding in python
julia does not have configurable
garbage collector which might not be
problem for many of you but if you
encounter some problems with garbage
collections and you want to tune the
constants of the garbage collector so it
would run run more often less often
you can't do it
just by calling some function in julia
and you need to recompile julia with
different flags which can be painful
especially if you want reproducible
builds and have the building of julia in
your ci pipeline
so
julia has some quirks
some of them are good some of them are
bad the good quirks are that you it has
macro to show you the generated assembly
from your function so
it's high-level language and you can see
the assembly that is being executed
which is nice and sometimes the assembly
fits one page even
you can force pre-compilation of some
packages because the julia has the
runtime which has just in time
compilation based on llvm and you can
enforce some compilation to be ahead of
time
because if you don't do this the first
run when the compilation happens is
quite slow because in julia you have the
code you run it and if it hasn't been
compiled for the specific types you are
calling it with
it it gets compiled and it can compile
quite a lot of code and that can be
quite slow
in julia it's called like tt
like time to first plot
like when you want to just plot some
some graph a function like the time to
first plot is the time from startup of
the program to time when the first spot
appears and it cut
and it can get quite high like sometimes
it takes minutes if you don't have
anything pre-compiled
which can be bothersome
you can manipulate the packages from
inside julia that julia has the package
manager which which runs inside julia so
if you have already running julia and
you figure out you need some new package
you just type package at the name of the
package which is great that you don't
have to kill the
runtime and
type pip install something and bring it
back up
that's very useful and saves you some
time but it has some caveats like
upgrading package if you are using old
package and you want to upgrade it if
you have already loaded the package into
the runtime
and it lo and you upgraded the package
the runtime already has the compiled
functions from the old version and
doesn't
uh
package registry which is git repo fully
managed by github bots that if you want
to run
if you want to register new version of
package or new package you just call
write comment regis julia registrator
register
your package and
the bot is triggered it creates pull
request with
the changes to the package registry and
then there is another bot which is
running on schedule performing
unit and integration tests on top of the
package registry and everything that
passes the test gets merged which is
quite neat
julia has broadcasting on language level
so if you want to call some function
on every element of an array
julia has native support for it so you
don't need to call like map
like in python you can just put dot
there and it gets broadcasted and you
can do type
multiple dispatch and specialize your
functions for the broadcasting
and julia has pipes similar to r which i
quite like
and the controversies julia is one base
has one based indexing
yes yeah it's controversial one
uh the package manager in julia as i
mentioned works well with git but it
also means
that there is like git everywhere it's
not the git
the official implementation the command
line it's
the gitlab c extension which has some
quirks like when you need to deal with
ssh keys and also proxy server it can
get quirky and
you don't google the answer because no
one has dealt with it
before you
and julia programmers can't shut up
about its type system me including
of course if you
don't handle the types well you get type
in stable code and that really hurts the
performance
and it's not that easy to hunt down
there are some tools which help you with
detecting the type stability of your
code but it can get tricky if your code
base is larger
yeah i spoke about the non the
non-flexible
gc
and the precompilation
and the cold start problem
get quite funky in docker because in
docker you have the layers and if you
want to pre-compile the julia so some of
the compilation would happen and the
build time of the docker image and not
during the startup of the container
because you want the container to start
up as soon as as quickly as possible
some of the code gets pre-compiled but
some doesn't and i tried to save like 10
minutes of our startup time of our
production containers by pre-compiling
it during the build time and i didn't
succeed
so our containers take sometimes like 10
minutes to actually start and run the
web server after everything is compiled
which is tricky in kubernetes when you
have to
configure probably the startup probe and
liveness probe and readiness probe so
kubernetes wouldn't kill your emit
container because it would think oh it's
stuck but your container is just
compiling lots of code
so
let us see some code
i prepared some really simple benchmark
in numpy and in julia
it's just looping over array oh in numpy
and also in play python so we have array
we just loop over it and we
multiply numb each number by two and
then power it by two
and in numpy you have the broadcasting
so you just
type the things and that's it indu and
then we have some branching so we have
condition and we want to multiply number
by two if it's less than one thousand or
multiply by three if it's more in numpy
i have used the vectorization trick who
has who have knew
who of you knows the vectorization trick
like this
to avoid branching
yes so you learn something so in numpy
you can do this
so you mult you compute the
both values
so you compute both multiple two and
three which is more costly than
computing only one of this
but
you multiply it by the condition which
gets
cast into the integer so you multiply by
1 and by 0 every element and it's really
fast
so it's like quite nice vectorization
magic which makes your python code quite
performant
and you can see the benchmark so for
we run it for 100 times and do stuff for
array of ten thousands which takes
almost quarter of a second in
pure
python but in numpy we take
10 times larger array it's 60
millisecond in 60 milliseconds in julia
it's 1 millisecond and 18 milliseconds
so for this dummy benchmark julia is
faster and also you can see here the
broadcasting if there is a dot it's a
broadcast like apply this function to
every element of an array so x is an
array you multiply every element by two
and then you power
the element by two and yeah this
i haven't used the vectorization trick
here i could have used that is but i'm
just looping there to see to show that
even with the looping it's faster than
numpy
so automatic differentiation which is
one of the other nice things about julia
who has heard about automatic
differentiation
okay and who has trained some neural
networks
okay so all of you who have turned some
trained some neural networks have used
automatic differentiation automatic
differentiation is a way to obtain
gradients or different
cis
derivatives of some functions with
respect to inputs so neural network is
just mathematical function
each layer is a function and it's like
nested function lots of nested functions
and if you
perform the gradient descent inside the
during the gradient
stochastic gradient descent if you
perform the one step of the gradient
descent you compute the gradient with
respect to the weights of the neural
network and you update the weights of
the neural networks based on this
gradient so you take the gradient
multiply it by the
learning rate and
subtract the
subtract it from the weights of the
neural network
so you need to obtain the gradient from
arbitrary function because you just type
your neural network layers and arbitrary
functions and you want to get derivative
of your code you have written and you
want to have it in automatic way
julia has native support which is great
but if you are using python you are
using tensorflow or pytorch they are
also able to do the automatic
differentiation they have it implemented
you just don't know about it mostly
so this is the example in julia there is
a package called zygote for the
differentiation because as we know from
biology zygote differentiates
in tensorflow yeah in tensorflow we just
use tensorflow and here we have pytorch
so
here i defined some
simple function that's like quadratic
optimization but here we are
the computing gradient with respect to x
which is not that
usual but just for the example
i defined one vector second vector one
matrix we just multiply the vector
transposed vector by matrix by the
vector
and add it to the transposed vector
times
that's the matrix multiplication
with the other vector this is our loss
function we compute it and then we call
gradient and we obtain our gradient with
respect to
x if you want to do this in tensorflow
you need to you can use the numpy arrays
for the
value for the values where you are not
computing gradient but if you want to
copy the gradient with respect to
variable you need to use tf variable
and you don't have this nice notation so
you need to have array in arrays
if you want to get matrix
and
tensorflow doesn't have
dot t for transposing so you need to
call the df transpose
and you need to
if you want to multiply by scalar value
you need to wrap it inside
and
inside np array otherwise it doesn't
work and then you can call your loss the
value is the same and you can either use
the computational graph which we don't
want to do because it's quite tedious
when you are experimenting so you use
gradient tape
and call the loss and then you call tape
gradient
and you get your gradient in pytorch
it's a bit nicer but you need to specify
if you want the gradient or not
when you are defining the variable
you can use the this is the python
notation for matrix multiplication
which is quite nice and after you
complete your loss you call loss
backward which performs the backward
pass
through the
computation and then you obtain your
gradient so
this is when julia is a bit nicer than
python
and you can flex with the macros so if
you want to see what is the assembly
code generated by the compiler when we
are computing the loss function this is
the assembly and it did fit into one
slide
so why would you want to use julia for
machine learning or why we at abas
decided to use julia for machine
learning
because in our use case we have
hierarchical data we don't have like
vector or tensor we have
dictionaries or arrays of dictionaries
this is a
small part of our training sample which
is
dictionary with single key which has
which is dictionary yeah which has two
keys scalar value or some array and here
it's
array of
dictionaries which contain array array
dictionary of array of
some numerical arrays numerical array
and numerical values so
we have quite wild data types and quite
nest quite
deep nested data
which have lots of different sizes for
example when we have arrays sometimes
the array is like 10 10 samples long
array sometimes it's 100 000 samples
long array so every sample in your
training
data can get quite big or quite small
and one sample can be like 10 000 times
larger than the other
which is really fun if you want to do
proper mini batching and utilize your
cpu
and we are also training with missing
values so if you don't have some value
and you have it missing
you don't want to put just zeros there
or some dummy value because that would
be
not that good you would just force the
neural networks to this value but you
can in julia it's flexible enough that
you can train some value instead so if
data is missing we can train the
vector instead of it and so the neural
network like
decides what is the best representation
for the missing data given the task you
are optimizing for which can be nice for
such weird data we are using
of course when you have like mini batch
where you have lots of different arrays
belonging to different samples you need
to aggregate it
and because you need to aggregate over
the samples in your mini batch we are
using segmented aggregations which are
also in tensorflow and by torch
sometimes we are using
sparse matrices because the data can be
quite sparse so it's better to sparta
sparse representation
also like if you have sparse data in
tensorflow and pytorch is also good to
use sparse representation because the
data then take
much less space on the gpu which is nice
but also our one our associate professor
has written
matrix multiplication optimized for
n-gram matrices so we have n-grams
we because we represent strings as
n-grams and we have optimized the
matrix multiplication of dense matrix by
n-gram
which is like four times faster than the
multiplication by sparse matrix
and it's differentiable which is nice
and if you have the all these things
with language like with support on the
language level you don't need to figure
out how to do something in numpy pi
torch or tensorflow because
you know python and then you need to
learn the numpy and tensorflow and pi
torch which is a bit like different
language because
if you don't do the operations inside
the framework it gets really
less efficient
so there are reasons why to use julia
and now the reasons why not to use it
for example we have at last have ci cd
pipelines and we use teamcity for that
teamcity is great
but and you can
click your things and your pipelines in
the web ui but we don't want to do that
because we are proper engineers we like
configuration as a code so we write
cotton dsl we have release engineering
department which take care of this for
most languages so they
have developed the scaffolding for like
python and other widely used languages
so you just call some functions which
then called the kotlin dsl which makes
the building of poetry package building
the docker image with it pushing it to
the register deploying into kubernetes
cluster and is great but if you go there
with julia you don't have any of that so
we needed to write all the kotlin dsl
for julia
which is not rocket science but it takes
some time and you need to have some
people who do that actually
and as i mentioned we are using
artifactory which does not have support
for julia package package registry so we
needed to figure out a way how to do
this
and luckily because julia package
registry is a git repo we just have git
repo but we needed to
create all the service accounts and
figure out how to safely
clone and pull the packages and so on
and of course because julia has a quite
long cold start
no one tells you how to tune it in
kubernetes cluster so you need to figure
out yourself
also
the http client now is quite good but
for example when you are
building at avast it's disconnected from
the public internet of course because we
want to safely
publish they publish packages to our
customers
so you can't get to the public date
public
internet but all the julia packages are
on the github and then mirrored on the
package registry
which is again on the public internet so
you need to use proxy server but the
http library for julia didn't have good
enough support for the
proxy environment variables and didn't
handle them properly so i needed to send
some requests to make it work
and there is erratic
garbage collection in kubernetes
sometimes
it's like it
we couldn't replicate it locally so we
were just debugging it inside kubernetes
cluster which was really fun
who have who of you has heard about the
malloc trim function
okay no one let me enlighten you if you
are using
c or g lib c for
memory man which is c library for memory
management you have the malloc catalog
and then the free function but the free
function frees the memory
but doesn't it free it from the process
itself it keeps the memory for the
process
so the process can then use it and
doesn't have to do all the negotiation
with the os
but if you are allocating lots of small
chunks and then need to allocate some
large chunk and then you
are continuously freeing it you are
filling it inside the process and not
returning it to the os so the malloc
trim returns the memory to os
so we had like 50 gigabytes of ram and
we ran out of ram because we had such
huge memory leaks so we just hacked some
random calling malloc trim and it works
like charm
we wanted to call it but not that often
because malloc trim can take like
yeah enforcing gc because you can
trigger the garbage collection and then
karma lock trim but they can take like
two minutes and you don't want your
world to freeze for two minutes when
it's running in production
so we have the we have like two replicas
in kubernetes and
during the
readiness probe there is the
like random number generator and when
it's lower than some magic number it
triggers the garbage collection so then
during the garbage collection the pot
isn't available but the second replica
is used instead and the probability is
low enough so they don't garbage collect
at the same time
it works it's magic it works it runs in
a production for one year and
is quite okay
but the disadvantage is that no one
outside of your team wants to touch it
and it's quite
surprising
yeah exactly
or it bothers you during the vacation
that the alerts that it's crashed and
it's quite surprised for new hires
because you hire someone to your team
and tell them there is something in
julia in production and we want you to
develop some new functions to it
and yeah we had
someone who
left not only because of this but
it's it's not for everyone definitely
so
as i mentioned you can call julia from
python and python from julia so you can
think okay
we can run we can
make all the
things we need in python and delegate to
julia only the part which julia is
really good at
and don't use the whole web server in
julia but use the one in python and just
call julia
there is the by julia to call julia from
python i call to call python from julia
it's really good for some simple
examples for example we were writing a
research paper and we included the quote
in julia and the reviewers complained
that it's not in python
so we
they so we decided that we'll include
one example in python using pycol so
they can run python jupiter notebook and
it calls the julia packages under the
hood
the integration between python julia has
native numpy support which is nice
because you
quite often need to transfer
large amounts of data and it lowers the
initial learning barrier because you can
just use python and it somehow and
install the julia and it does all the
other things
so
i could show you how it looks like
oh yes sorry
yeah here i have jupiter lap and i can
show you the
python and julia so we have the python
kernel in jupiter lab
we installed by julia like this
we have some julia binary which we link
there
and then
we can just import some julia modules
from
yeah inside the python and here this is
calling the julia package or you can
just use the eval function because both
jury and python have eval which is
really dangerous but really easy to work
with if you want to show something if
you are using jupiter it also has the
magic macro so you can call julia magic
and if you type the person julia you can
write julia code
and as i was showing the quadratic
optimization you can use julia to
compute your gradients
so you just define the numpy arrays and
then you
build the loss function in julia
you create it
and then you call zygote gradient and
you get your gradients and also if you
define some function in python you can
call it from julia like this
and this is the
these are the jupiter notebooks for the
paper that this is the julia kernel so
that's all native julia
which is the language some reviewers
don't want to use so this is the python
one
so here we install the julia oh they
need to have provide the julie path to
julia binary but it's python kernel and
here we install all the packages so you
just can call the package manager from
inside the jupyter notebook and then use
it it just takes some time so it runs
for like five minutes this cell because
it needs to pre-compile all the code as
i mentioned you set up some things and
then you can
oh yeah this was the error but it worked
when i set up the environment variables
properly and you can train your define
your neural network and train it
yeah and it works
quite well
but there are caveats to this approach
too
if you want to differentiate some
functions you need to define them in
julia because if you define the
functions
in python and then put them to julia the
automatic differentiation is not able to
go from lung from one language to the
other and crashes so
you can differentiate your code from
julia to python
also transferring larger data is a bit
slow if it's numpy array it's okay but
if it's like large parts json so the if
you have like one gigabyte large json
which is dictionary of arrays of
dictionaries of arrays that can get
quite slow also the
lip giulia is not thread safe so you
can't have multiple python threads and
call lip julia from each of them
that would be cool because
you could have like multi multi-thread
python web server and use this
and you can say to yourself okay i will
have multiple processes i don't need
threads in
vsgi web servers you can just type many
multiple processes as you probably know
so you can say okay i want
four python processes in ufsg or g
unicorn
and it runs
but if you want to use julia with that
the
multiple python processes can't share
the same julia process
so each process runs its own julia and
if you have neural networking julia
which takes one gigabyte in of ram
if you have four processes it's for
julia's with four gigabytes of ram which
is unfortunate
so there is no free launch here
and you can't easily mutate data so if
you have some by some julia dictionary
called from created in python you can't
mutate it it's immutable and you need to
create the one created from create new
one created from merging the
two dictionaries which can be bothersome
and
can shoot you in the lag
so when to use it in production if you
have people who are willing to do this
and who are comfortable with julia and
if you have people to take care of
infrastructure or if you don't have
infrastructure to take care of
and it's worth to do it if
rewrite from python to julie from julia
to python
would take more time than taking care of
the infrastructure for example i tell us
we already had some packages in julia
which some associate professor already
has used has used for a few years and we
decided okay let's use julia instead of
rewriting it all to python
and that's why we have julian production
so if i there are little cases where you
want to use julia and python doesn't
suffice ben is great
and if you really do did your due
diligence so
remember these things i have told you
when you will be deciding if you want to
use julian production
yeah
the code i have shown is in this repo
so
thank you for your attention and any
questions
[Applause]
so um should i read something from style
or is there someone content out directly
okay
yeah i have a question so if you take
python syntax and you would like to run
it as julia what what is the blocking
part why can't we use python syntax to
run industry
yeah in
yeah there are some
syntactic differences like in python you
use depth keyword
injury use function
and in python you have indentation in
julia you have like begin and end which
you can do programmatically like replace
it
so that would work but
some code works like this if you have
like small enough code base it works
like this if you have larger code base
the problem is python is object oriented
july is not
so you have structures you don't have
objects so in python you have the
inheritance you enjoy you have multiple
dispatch
so then if you get to objects you can't
do it one-to-one because you need to
translate the inherit the inheritance to
multiple dispatch
okay
okay another question and
sorry
what is the hiring situation
do people on the job market know julia
or do you train them in-house
yeah
we have hired some people to our team
and
i think none of them has known julia
before so we trained them in-house so
far we have had some senior people who
are able to learn julia
or at least they heard about julia from
one of associate professors who is
really promoting julia at the university
so they have heard about it and
then they learned it at work
so
yeah they have
they have earned it and we are hiring
and also two teams that don't use julia
we are using python quite a lot and are
hiring for
python positions
which is important
so then maybe just just
just just to have some some like feeling
about it uh
how many more people i know python than
julia do you know like
the ratio can you guess i don't know is
it 100 to one or is it like 1 000
it's i think it's like really hard to
guess because i guess that is the
problem with the
level because there i guess that there
will be 100 to 1 if you consider the
people that are learning how to program
and are just typing the hello world then
there is a huge amount of people who are
learning to program and really their
first programming steps in python
there's loads of them that's why python
is one of the most popular languages
and number of julia people doing this is
really small but
if you like
really like strong machine learning
engineers then i think the ratio is
less that just there is the bigger gap
between the
good senior engineers and beginners in
python than in julia of course in julia
the there is less senior people but
there is more senior people than
beginners in julia compared to
python okay so another question
given the bit broken one given the
number of issues is it still worth it
have you thought about reverting back to
python
or some other language we are actually
doing this
because at the beginning it wasn't
planned to deploy so many production
applications
and on the way we decided okay we need
to
deploy more things to production so the
shortest path to was to use julia but if
we had known
the grand plan from the beginning we
would have used python probably
okay so there's another question that i
don't probably understand well um is
julia more stable uh
probably with regards to python or
well it depends on like which level of
stability
you mean i think like the ecosystem is
more unstable because it's still
evolving so
the chance that some
package
would get
like abandoned i think is a bit greater
in julia than in python so the like
i think in this regard the python is
more stable but
i'm thinking about the like different
like interpretations of stability i
think like definitely if you consider
type stability joule is more type stable
than python
also
yeah i think it's a bit
yeah maybe a bit like more stable in
production in the manner in the sense
that
in julia once the code is compiled
the
runtime of the code get has lower
variance because it's
the interpreter doesn't do some magic
there but in python
the peaks
can get bit higher because
the interpreter is a bit more magical
than the compiler when the when there is
some long run time i think
yes another question from the audience
so the transition from july to python
doesn't have a price thing you know like
are you gonna pay more for the servers
i don't know about this kind of price
tech
definitely it's
like with people it's simpler to hire
people from for python than for julia
but
i don't know for the
servers
if it's cheaper in runtime for julia or
python
because we're not in cloud we're on prem
so we just use the hardware we have and
we don't know how much did it cost when
they were buying it
okay so maybe i have a question yeah uh
in the last meetup there was a talk
about how to
compile the python interpreter to web
assembly and
how to actually run python code within
browser do you think it would be
possible to do something like that in
julia for julia well julia
i don't know if web assembly is
compatible with llvm
if it is then it's possible if it isn't
then not okay so it's like it's the
heart requirement that it yeah yeah but
also the rust is using llvm i think
so it boils down to like similar thing
as rust in
rust to web
assembly okay any other questions
you mentioned uh uh i julia so the
package you called the titan was not um
let's say could you use async i also
have to avoid hiding
and use it still asynchronously
i think you could yeah with yeah with i
think io i think it would work but i
haven't tried that
okay
so if there are not any other questions
we have thanks thanks maggie